you
[Music]
one of the big challenges of my life has
been to kind of break down this barrier
as scientists being somehow the other
you know being a scientist isn't really
a normal way to be a human being and
somehow there are all these judgments
about that you must be very logical or
you must be very smart whatever that
means and no one ever seems to really
understand that when you learn where the
atoms in your body came from you know
when you learn the scale of the universe
when you learn the stories that you're
involved in there has to be some
emotional response to that you know that
just doesn't roll off you and never
affect you and I don't really have a
great way to deal with everything that
I've learned being an astrophysicist you
know if I ever give people the
impression that all this is just okay
with me that's entirely wrong there are
days when you know I understand that I
am a collection of atoms that came from
the hearts of stars that briefly comes
together and forms planets and people
and and everything that's in our world
and then you know I was observing one
night in Mount Palomar where we were
observing super novae and supernovae
czar the explosions of an entire solar
system whole solar system is destroyed a
star at all of its planets and our
telescopes are so good now that a
typical night at Mount Palomar you see
about 20 of those a night you know you
see 20 entire solar systems ripped apart
every night so we're here very briefly
you know we're little collections of
atoms that come together and scatter and
then form other things and you know
travel on through the universe and
sometimes that's incredibly inspiring
and sometimes you think about the story
that you're a part of you know the the
water in my body has hydrogen from the
Big Bang from the very start of the
universe then the oxygen came from stars
that had to die you know you you hold
your arms around yourself and you have a
story that's billions of years and you
know trillions of miles across just in
your own self and then you think about
how brief we are and how
you know we are this little collection
that comes together and disperses and it
you know it sometimes I hide under the
bed and it's given me anxiety attacks
and you cling to the people that you
love and you have sex with all the wrong
people and you try to find some way to
just kind of work out this energy that
you you don't know what to do with so
there's there's a balance between kneel
ISM and inspiration and I have to say
that while that balance is sometimes
painful because you're a human being and
you don't know how to deal with this
scale of things it is an absolutely
wonderful place to walk that that
balance between being part of everything
and being so brief for almost nothing
and you have to hold those two things in
your hands at the same time and
everybody you meet and everything you do
in life and when you're out grocery
shopping and when you're driving on the
highway these thoughts just don't really
ever leave so it's not the easiest place
to be there's no great answer there
there's no great comfort but the
inspiring part is you're part of a story
that is mind-blowing ly dramatic and
beautiful even if you're a brief part
and so to me the balance tips towards
inspiration some days it's more towards
the knee ilysm but you you take that
little bit of truth and you wrap it up
and you carry it with you and it never
really leaves
[Music]